you
mr. Lucia thank you very much for being
with us here today and if we could start
off as dean saloner said you've worked
in many different countries across the
world and worked in many different
businesses perhaps we could start by
asking are there some common threads
that you've identified with all of the
leaders that you've met that you would
say define leadership in you I think
there are many many definitions of
leadership surround the world so I will
not be the one who will add another one
but I mean if you think about maybe we
can talk a little bit in terms of what
what I personally consider as as key
traits of good leaders I think the first
one I would say is clarity of direction
and vision second one is and that's the
probably a skill in itself that how you
break it then down in actionable steps
short term medium and long term which is
then linked to the capacity of the
organization and to your competitive
environment what you're facing so that
you challenge the organization that you
challenge the environment but you make
the possible possible in the fastest
time what you can and what you're able
to implement so how you execute well in
this regard the third one I would say is
that you have to be absolutely
passionate because without passionate or
not to be able to rally your team's
behind you
the fourth one I would say you you have
to be absolutely determined in pursuing
what you have set out for the
organization and for me one the fifth
one is I would say is that you have to
have a true north for yourself
irrespective of of of kind of company
values or company culture that you
clearly define for yourself what's right
and what's wrong
and then you are on to the field to play
and onto the field you were in so said
the first outside CEO in Demon's history
I imagine that created some specific
leadership challenges for you perhaps
you could talk about these principles
that you mentioned and how you applied
those as you took over as CEO president
ever since I mean is who has actually
read and worked through the case can you
just show me my hands up well I don't
have to explain anything I mean
obviously is it was a very defining
moment for the company it was a very
defining moment for myself I mean it was
the twelve CEO in the history of the
company the first one coming from the
outside and the the company itself was
in a major in a major shock so the first
thing what I had to do is is is really
to make sure that what happened to the
organization was never part of the
company culture so the first thing what
I set out for the organization to
clearly differentiate that we had a
major leadership crisis to deal with to
deal with and to tackle with but it was
not a company culture issue per se what
we had to deal with so for me the
resolving is this issue and the fastest
possible time was obviously the highest
priority the second one is is then when
you are the first one coming from the
outside in a in this way on to the on to
the management board is that you know
this I mean it's the natural things I
mean who is this person I didn't have a
broad following in Germany because I
spend all my life across the world so
the first question was actually who is
he
the second question probably was will he
bring his own team with with him will he
change everything what we have done in
the past well he tried to revolutionize
the company or not so I very clearly
said out and said the CMAs doesn't need
a revolution but we will continue to
have an evolution but we will do this
with speed speed speed speed
so the third element was then the
the first crisis what I have but I
really had to deal with and this is this
whole corruption case and how to make
sure that we deal with it and it in any
extremely forceful transparent and open
manner and I knew that I had to bring in
people from the outside to help in this
one
so my first key appointments in the
organization were absolutely critical
and this was Peter storm since the chief
legal counsel who worked with me in GE
and then also the chief compliance
officer so that I had actually a team
onto there who I can really trust and
who can really work with the overall
organization to tackle this most
pressing issue what we have to deal with
and then you very quickly move on to to
really say I wanted to have hundred days
I wanted to have hundred days for the
simple reason that I wanted to really
see as many people as I could
listen travel around the world
engage the organization from the
customer viewpoint from the different
parts of the world get feedback get
input and at the same time worked and
with my top leadership team what has to
be changed and then the whole thing
evolved around structural changes
leadership changes and so on and so
forth and you have read the case I don't
have to repeat all of it but the initial
part was very much making sure that I am
visible to as many people of the
organization as possible so I had a lot
of skip level meetings for example I
made deliberate efforts that I made big
town hall meetings all over the world we
have been on different sites why me we
have met the young leaders of the
organization and so on and so forth that
I have really an interaction very
different level of the organization that
I also get an input from the customer
viewpoint so a classically day if you
ask me what is a classically day within
Siemens and I think it's probably still
valid today and this is what I have
basically developed over many many many
years I I come in into the morning
basically start breakfast with with a
group of customers followed by a meeting
with politicians or with single
customers and on big contracts then I go
into having
with the young high potentials meet me
alone and nobody else then followed by
business reviews town hall meetings and
then a joint dinner with the top
leadership team and if you do this day
after day you get a very very solid and
very quick understanding what are the
true issues and what you have to
calculate are the most pressing one what
you have to deal with this here as a
leader there's a leadership team and as
as Siemens has evolved over the last
three years it has four hundred thousand
people across the world how do you
affect change when you have so many
different businesses in so many
different countries and so many
individual people who you need to
persuade and to get on board with the
way you're thinking about the company I
mean the first thing you say is that you
have to recognize that you have to rely
on many many other people so you need to
work number one with the United top
leadership team so the first issue what
you have to deal with is how do you make
sure that you really work with your team
who you trust and who you speak and who
speaks with one voice in one direction
and acts and speaks in the same way so
how do you quickly get basically
different change agents in the
organization who were really aligned
with what you try to accomplish in the
in the organization for this reason the
change what I have introduced in terms
of the CEO principle was exactly this to
absolutely make sure that I had then the
leaders in place who I trusted who
believed in the same vision who work in
the same direction with the same speed
how how how I wanted to change happening
in the organization and then through the
prints of what I've just announced and
I'm traveling seventy percent of my time
being in front of the organization as
much as you can yourself because there's
nothing more important than the personal
and direct dialogue with the with the
teams around the world and as as you've
evolved as a leader and if we broaden it
out just beyond Zeman's could you talk
perhaps about how your personal style of
leadership has evolved over time and as
you've encountered different challenges
in the different companies you've worked
in how has that caused you to reflect on
your personal style of leadership
I think it's very I mean look at this
crowd I always look at all of you I mean
you have police
how many nations are here in Stanford 50
nations so you see my my grandmother's
Italian my parents are Austrians my wife
is Spanish two of my Chilean Americans
the third one is Spanish and I'm
Austrian so I have learned I have
learned to be a minority and I've
learned to actually have a very acute
cultural sense and this is very
important because the world is very
different and when you then have the big
opportunity what I got really owned in
like in life to work in Asia to study in
Asia in the US and in in European
countries you you're not just broaden
you are your skillset you hone your
instinct and you also realize that that
there are many many avenues to reach a
certain goal post and you know all of
these so I don't have to really repeat
it but if I give you three examples I
mean in the US everybody knows that you
can lead very much by objective setting
vision setting objective setting and
then you basically work your plan and
the people will very much align
themselves in doing so and when you then
go to to Spain for example do we have
Spanish colleagues here so the first
thing what you realize is that you have
to allow far more time for talking
so when you try to align the
organization the first prints of what
you have to adhere to is that you allow
the teams to really that they have he
could talk among themselves and then
this is how you create alignment but
it's very very important that you give
this you cannot just set it from the
from the top and say this is what we
will do and this is how it looks like
and these are the action steps and I ask
you to follow because they won't but you
get a very strong and buy-in if if you
do it the other way around when you then
go to Asia you have a very similar type
of leadership requirement you you must
make sure that you that you engage the
organization from a bottom-up
perspective and then align it in
different initiatives top-down and
bottom-up so and this is the privilege
what I had in my life that I grew up in
in different cultural environments I
worked in different environments and
this helped me a lot in terms of how I
appreciate the diversity of the world
and also how to be most effective in
cross-cultural teams which is the true
asset of a global company like ours and
if we talk about you have such a large a
large organization you talked about the
young leaders that you have I think for
a group of high potential leaders like
us perhaps you could talk about
by the way this is exactly what I
assumed because otherwise you wouldn't
be here
but let's talk about the other side of
that what do you think of the most
common mistakes that you see young
leaders in your organization make and
what could we learn from those mistakes
this is a very broad question look I
mean the first the first advice what I
would have is I mean all of your leaders
otherwise you wouldn't be here but I
think as leaders being young or older
the first thing what we have to
recognize is how privileged we are and I
give you now a quote but what was a
great learning for me from Jack Welch I
met Jack in the mid 90s through a
benchmarking exercise when I then joined
the GE organization he was on his book
tour and I met him in his signing with
his latest book so say Jack I'm here now
officer of GE what is your one line of
advice you know that he gave me a one
line of advice Peter give it all Jack
and I think live your dreams and make
sure that you live up to the to the
capacity and what you have is
individuals and make a real contribution
through the work what you do for others
and I think this is the great privilege
what we have this is what what leaders
have to think of in terms of what is
their impact not just from a from a from
a economic perspective but also
ecological perspective social
perspective and the impact what we have
for for many many millions of people and
for me it was always a great privilege I
spent many many years of my life in the
pharmaceutical business for a very
simple reason because I I was enormously
privileged to work on technologies and
help people to live a better life and to
survive and when you then talk to
patients and you feel really the impact
what you have this makes me very very
proud of that's a great privilege of
being a CEO seen as being in so many
businesses this is this is where the
impact water or the big
organization like ours have is enormous
and that's an enormous enormous
privilege but I guess with that
privilege becomes a lot of
responsibility in leaders and when when
you look at these high potential leaders
you mentioned you have lunch with them
many days I think a lot of us feel that
we learn the most when we struggle on
one we face challenges perhaps you could
talk a little bit more about when you
you talk to these is what are the
challenges that they are dealing with
because these I think are the challenges
that that we might face in the next two
to three years I always tell my team
look I mean when I look into this room
here how many of you will join big
global organizations like Siemens one
two three four or five and that's the
reality you want to become entrepreneurs
you look for very different fulfillments
in your life I mean when I was at
Harvard and and we were talking about
what where when you go through the last
20 years I mean it was 20 years ago it
was probably you know it was the issue
at one point there was the peak
organizations then there was the whole
wave of the consultancy stand with a big
wave of of the financial industry and
the most most promising perspective
right now is to be a real
entrepreneurship so making it for
yourself and create something for
yourself and and and you are here in
your back yards Silicon Valley and I was
quite impressed I said learned from the
Dean actually two minutes ago that 40%
of you will actually start to work there
that's great
so for a big organization like Siemens
it is very you are not waiting till you
are middle-aged and gray there's
somebody in life will tell you and now
you're fully responsible you are asking
for the responsibility far earlier than
any generation before you you also have
an enormous privilege like all of us
when we compare the change what is now
happening in
world being a technological change being
it the global change which is happening
it is happening in one management
generation the type of change which used
to happen within three so there's an
enormous compressed way of opportunity
there's an enormous opportunity space so
big organizations have to make sure how
they are attractive for a young
population like yourself who is asking
for broader experience and more
responsibility far earlier than any
other management generation before you
and that's the challenge and that's the
type of opportunity space which big
companies have to face and when we look
at this this next generation of leaders
how do you think the challenges that
they will face as leaders you've talked
about them having more responsibility
earlier but how do you see the other
challenges they face as leaders as being
different from from the current
generation and from generations before
them I think as I said it I mean the big
change is if you just talk about the
globalization which is currently
happening in the world it's it's with a
speed which is enormous
I grew up for example in my first
studies I studied in Austria and the
Iron Curtain was actually just happening
in the backyards of Vienna and I was
crossing this this Iron Curtain several
times I could not imagine really I could
not imagine that I will ever see in my
life that this would change this for me
was something which was given and look
what happened just through this one
thing how the world has changed now we
are going through a major crisis and we
see all of a sudden the political
architecture changing dramatically going
from a g7 g8 or g20 the emerging markets
they are asking offer far more
responsibility not just economically but
also politically when you then look
where 97% of incremental population
growth will happen it will happen in the
emerging economies so there is and they
want to have the same way and
opportunity space then we have in our in
our lifespan sitting here in at the
university so the change what you have
in the impact I would not like to talk
in terms of challenges but your
portunities what you have is the impact
what Friedman was talking about you know
a flat world which is absolutely a
reality right now the impact what new
technology can bring in terms of mass
impact is in a way democratized like
never before and this creates an
enormous new opportunity space for each
one of you and find your space go for it
and make an impact and make an impact
economically but also socially and
community wise and I think this is
exactly what what this opportunity space
is I think in order to do that all of us
have benefited from mentors in our life
to provide us guidance and to help us
understand the potential that exists for
us
you mentioned Jack Walsh earlier are
there any particular mentors that you've
had and what do you think were the most
important things you learned from them I
mean well first of all I didn't have
them in I don't go back and say this was
one mentor which was great but you learn
from each one of the people you
interface with maybe one maybe one story
which was for me very very very telling
when I was 27 years of age I I joined a
big German company called Rix at that
time was a big chemical company and the
CEO was used to be my mate
used to be my mentor and he hired me and
I was he said look start working wait
here six months and then come back and
then let's talk about what you would
like to do with him within our
organization I had met one page and I
was clearly mapping it out but I would
like to do and this and this and he I
showed up in his office and then he was
listening to minutes and then he turned
it away and said you know I give you an
advice
have fun enjoy the things what you're
doing and make sure the people you work
with are equally enjoyable and then
everything what we have written here
will happen automatically and that's a
great advice because never tried to plan
any career I never try to chart but
whatever you do try to do it in the best
possible way and then go for it it's a
great advice to me what I got from for
myself and as as you become a senior and
by the way at that time my ambition
level was to become the CEO of Hook's
Austra as I guess you are perhaps now a
mentor to other people in your
organization could you perhaps talk
about how you feel playing that role now
as being a mentor to that next
generation of leaders and yeah this is
very important I mean with when you ask
me what is one of the most rewarding
aspects what I what I spend time with is
really we have now introduced a new
mentoring scheme for for all the board
members for all my colleagues as well
where I have basically 15 mentees all
across the world with different
backgrounds and we rotate them every two
years so there are mentees for two years
and then they are rotated to the next
and this is for me extremely rewarding
so I work very closely and and and you
know the mentee is responsible for them
for the mentor relationship it works in
different ways it is very personal and I
try to provide feedback to them and give
them advice from my experience and also
at the same time get to know what where
where their challenges are and to make
sure that the right steps are taken and
that they are stretched in the right
possible way within the organization so
the mentee mentor relationship is
something which is enormously enjoyable
for me personally and I spent quite
significant part of my time to make sure
that I stayed in touch with them and
that we have a continuous dialogue and
before we open it to questions one last
theme that we've seen in the last five
years is a much closer tie between
business and government what has been
your experience of that trend and how do
you think that's likely to evolve in the
next five to ten years oh absolutely I
mean there's this well it's absolutely
true number one particularly for big
infrastructure companies like ourselves
when you think about a big company like
Siemens we say at the end of the day our
whole business is infrastructure than
medical infrastructure being energy
infrastructure or building now with
master city the next generation of a
city environment so all of it is really
big infrastructure programs and and and
there you have at one side you face
government's as regulators you face
government as customers the whole
stimulus programs as part of the what we
have seen during the crisis so
absolutely the and then you have you
know economists who are in who are very
closely linked between infrastructure
development programs and the political
agenda around the world so there's a
very close alignment it's getting closer
and it's a very important one for a
particular company like ourselves at
this point I'd like to open it up to
questions we have microphones on either
sides if people could put hands up and
we'll get a mic to you Janet we'll start
down here
hello thank you very much I wanted to
ask you what clean tech opportunities do
you see for Latin America I mean this is
a I will answer this question but I will
start a little bit broader it's very
it's a very important question what
you're asking when you when when I
joined Siemens I asked the question what
is all clean tech portfolio and nobody
could give me an answer about the clean
tech portfolios because it was actually
in in the businesses in different you
know there was different solutions but
nobody actually looked across and said
this is our clean tech portfolio we need
renewables or being it energy-efficient
so when we have for the first time lined
it up so I started in 2007 I asked this
question by July 2008 we had for the
first time actually developed our clean
tech portfolio and it was 17 billion
euro the biggest and broadest clean tech
portfolio of any company in the world in
the mean time we have set out an
objective of 25 billion it would be we
will overachieve it already this year
and we will and we have by far the
biggest infrastructure company and this
is what I set out as a vision for the
company to be a green infrastructure by
India so that's the major major
strategic emphasis of the company across
all business lines to make sure that the
next generation of product development
are more resource efficient and energy
efficient and when we have the highest
speed trains and the highest speed
trains are only consuming 0.33 litres
for per 100 kilometers per passenger
then it's the most energy-efficient high
speed train as well not just the fastest
one and when you look into the
sustainability agenda around the world
it is plate and clear that this is on
the highest political priority level
despite the fact that coke
has not succeeded to bring into any
climate change agreement but when you're
talking about two mayor's around the
world that 1% of the population are
cities of square meters are cities
consuming 75 percent of energy
consumption 80 percent of co2 emissions
you know that this is the biggest
challenge around the world and in South
and Latin America and this is all around
the world when you then talk about and
you go from you talk about the Olympic
Games for example Brazil or the football
World Cup the big big and the resort and
the and the infrastructure development
programs which are currently put into
into place if all the agenda of making
sure that the latest generation of
infrastructure development is
significantly better in terms of
sustainable urban infrastructure
development programs than any other
generation before so you have this in
Latin America equal it was for example
last week I was together with Panero the
President of Chile again we have
immediately worked on a program how can
actually Chile now introduce the latest
technology of clean tech to really make
sure that they benefit for example of
their solar intensity what they have and
how can we bring together solar programs
that they make sure that in their
biggest cities are the mobility
infrastructure programs which are now
build out with the latest technology far
far more resource and consuming less
resource resources than before so it's a
big big program across all political
scopes being at in Latin America being
it in this country I mean Obama has made
a big big big push in terms of clean
tech being not just being also a big job
engine how the economy will be revived
if you go to Asia to to China for
example it's it's a massive government
agenda so you have it all over the world
and you see also it and
you definitely see it also in Latin
America hi thank you very much for being
here as far as mr. Latura a question I
have for you is the following
over the past 100 years the German
precise traditional way of doing things
has served Siemens very well in
developing its infrastructure that we
see now we see a bigger trend towards
need for innovation and more high speed
how do you manage to change that culture
and foster this kind of Silicon Valley
startup kind of culture inside such a
big company that's a very important
question because at the end of the day
is of any company 90% of the innovation
is happening outside the walls of the
company so yeah we have a big programs
for example currently what we call
internally open innovation historically
our labs which we have already all over
the world we have one here on the west
coast we have one in Princeton on the
East Coast we have it in Asia we have it
in Germany we have it in 30 countries
around the world where we have research
and development activities ongoing
currently a number one the network will
be wider but historically our research
and developers have very much focused
their time on what is happening in their
own labs and now the focus is shifting
and this is why we call it open
innovation that we make sure where is in
all the technology fields which are in
our sphere of interest where are the big
partner networks outside partner
networks where we have to link with to
make sure that that we innovate faster
relative to our competitors so we have a
big push basically driving the
innovation agenda outside our own
boundaries engaging with with big
research institutions or big
universities or was small companies and
innovative companies to make sure that
we have the most innovative network
available to us in the big technology
fields which which are our interests
that's it that's a very that's a
important push it's a very strategic one
and this will be very important because
there's nothing more demo Democratic
than innovation process around the world
and when you look into where where big
big innovative centers are happening of
course its United States but when you
just go by sheer size we have round if
if I give you the numbers right now you
have just graduations ok I'm talking
about
technically graduations in Germany we
have roughly forty five to fifty
thousand technically graduates every
year in India they're around three
hundred twenty thousand in China you
talk about eight hundred thousand that
the numbers a little bit there's a range
between 800,000 and one point and closer
to and closer to a million so we see
very much
the gravity centers of innovation
changing shifting and we have to take
advantage of it to the fact that we are
already present in hundred ninety
countries of the world and therefore we
should have a very good advantage with
great reputation in this markets that we
are able to tap into these new networks
and then we have also a venture capital
fund internally you know we have where
for example the font is available for
for internal research programs as well
as for partner companies as well hello
sir thank you you talk here about at the
beginning you said setting vision and
having clarity and strong leadership and
I think very charismatic leadership but
some in some of our classes here
especially in OB we learned that
sometimes it's good to use the skip the
high skills of the group to to to set to
set to be facilitative to be
participative so how do you balance
those two yeah but this is what I'm not
sure I mean when this is exactly what I
mean I think at the end of the day it's
always the team okay it doesn't matter
who
an individual never really matters as
much as any high-performance team and
this is why I have also pushed for
example in the Organization for
diversity I'm on record as I said the
management is too wide to mail to German
well when I when I joined the
organization because I think you have to
tap into the diversity pool what you
have is a global organization and when
you have the great privilege that you
are at home in hundred ninety countries
of the world that you are able to
attract the best talents to develop the
best immense talents and make them
available for the global organization
from a team perspective as well as from
an individual perspective this is a very
very critical element and we have on top
of individual responsibilities but you
would be responsible for many many
programs where we particularly look into
initiatives corporate initiatives and
pulling into these initiatives very
diverse teams from all over the world to
really help us to drive the change
agenda so that's at the at the
cornerstone of what we try to do but
this is always in the framework of the
clarity of vision what you try to have
of an organization so the teams they
really have to work towards the ultimate
end of the of the focus of the overall
organization but leveraging the the
diversity of team I mean I don't have to
explain this this is probably one of the
great great privilege what you have
working together yeah join again thank
you sir
my question is looking forward to the
next ten years what is the single most
important strategic issue that you have
to face as CEO and how are you gearing
the company to actually address that
issue I said it's the wrong question
I tell you why because as an innovative
as an innovation company which is an
infrastructure company the innovation
cycles of many of our products are going
for example for 10 years 15 years 20
years for example we are now bringing to
the market the most energy-efficient gas
turbine of the world the initial part of
the development programs goes back to
the early 90s when we talk about the
current high speed train which were
which were currently selling the initial
development programs go back to the mid
90s so when we talk about the innovation
agenda to be in a in innovation leaders
in the fields where we have focused on
when the industry sectors we are looking
way above the 10-year time horizon we
really have to look into 20 years you
can look from am from an how you
implement in terms of this the different
strategies you can look five to 10 years
but when they then say okay what is our
innovation advantage what we would like
to see in this area the time horizon is
way way longer than the 10 years so we
set out as as the strategic direction
for the company being the green
infrastructure pioneer so the pioneering
spirit what you have read in the in the
in the case is very much at the
forefront what we try to drive so
there's a big innovation agenda in the
in in all areas this is not a single
business field what we are looking for
but we are looking for to really making
sure that the energy efficiency of all
products going forward are significantly
more energy efficient and that we drive
the organization towards tailor-made
solutions for big big customers for
example which are not in the in the in
the forefront of a classic you Siemens
customer
the classically siemens customer would
be if there is a tender if if there's
pal alto or anywhere else and they would
say there's a great tram but we would
now like to develop and there's a tender
process and then we would be off and
running to go in after the tender but to
engage master city and to say what can
we drive together to help you to
implement the vision of a co2 free city
environment and what can we from a
technology perspective to implement to
link together the energy smart grid
infrastructure with the smart building
infrastructure that all the energy
consumption which is happening in the
city is able to communicate with each
other and optimize and being optimized
in terms of the energy efficiency of
buildings of energy flows across the
city and therefore ultimately helped to
drive massively down the energy costs of
master city this is an innovation
partnership what we are now pulling
together with master city classical
spirit there's no tender in this context
but there is a big big strategic
alliance where we work together with
master city to really drive it and
that's at the forefront what Siemens is
all about or this attic where we
basically try to harness the Sun of
Africa not just for for the African
countries themselves but also ultimately
being available for importing towards
Europe is a big vision which is 10 to 15
years out where we work with an
innovation partnership together with the
governments of Africa and with the
European Union what is the right funding
which is required what is the technology
which is already today available
high-voltage direct-current technology
so that we can transmit energy without
any losses over long periods of time so
the big big programs which are
infrastructure programs going beyond one
customer much more into a strategic
alliance and innovation partnership is
the big big
liebherr for the organization going
forward and this is where we drive the
strategic impact of Siemens versus just
selling products and services and being
attentive to tenders which we ultimately
obviously have to do in all our business
lines so the tactic so the vision is the
vision of Master City was a vision of
the Abu Dhabi government so I engaged
very much at the top level of the
political environment of Abu Dhabi to
say let's pull together a small team of
your people who are responsible for
master city under the leadership of dr.
Sultan was the CEO of master city and
our team so the two of us then pulled an
operational team together of the of
creating a strategic alignment we worked
for 18 months because you have to really
break it down what is the requirements
of the city how is the layout of the
city what are the different steps of
phase 1 and phase 2 it's now slightly
delayed because of the impact of the
current crisis but they're continuing
with the vision so we worked for 18
months and a week ago I was able to sign
it in London this is how we have worked
and to broken it down with a very
specific initiative ultimately being
able to decide you are said earlier one
of your five values of leadership was um
was to have a true north that transcends
company values company norms could you
talk to us about your true north how you
came to that true north and yeah why
that is your true north I think this
comes back I say a true north because it
goes back the first environment where
you really
learn about it are the values within
your family and the first role model for
me personally was my own father and then
you have a lot of opportunities and
privileges like every university like
Stanford University where you'll
probably have a lot of leadership in
terms of ethics ethical behavior and
business ethics and I for this reason
for example have actually sponsored a
also an educational initiative at the
Technical University of Munich to to
really provide these aspects at at the
university level because at the end of
the day this goes back to families the
values of the families and the values of
the education where you are brought up
with and then many of you I assure you
many of you in your life will be faced
in one way or another to make a personal
decision do I do something why don't in
different contexts you know sometimes
the cultural norms under Tsar where you
say and then you have to say no I live
up to my own standard with my own norm
and I'm not willing to go for it for
example this whole primary case in
Siemens when you read the testimonies of
people this is why I said this was a
leadership crisis this was not the
cultural crisis of the company but this
was a leadership attitude of some
leaders who have decided a red line for
me is not a red line and when you then
look into the testimonies what they have
given the classically testimony is well
I have done it to the benefit of the
company come on
people were pursuing this because they
had sales incentives as well and
ultimately they have made 10 cent of
schemes so this is what I mean it you
don't have to talk about company values
this is the next level where you then
have obviously and I would very much
encourage you with whatever organization
you you join is make sure how are the
company values not as values but how are
they actually left who are the role
models of the organization and who are
the role models of leaders and can you
relate to them and if somebody asks you
the most dangerous thing what you will
encounter is I have to do things because
everybody does and it's up to each one
of you to decide to say no I don't do it
period
. and this is what i mean it true north
i have also encountered this in my
professional life for sure we had to the
next question we've got one at the back
over there sir you spoke about the how
young people are asking for more
responsibility at an earlier and earlier
age for that model to work that means
young people have to be able to accept
and succeed and with this more
responsibility so i wonder from your
point of view do you believe that the
skills and abilities of young people are
changing commensurately with their
changes in expectations and desires what
do you think about this about you yeah i
think i think i think it comes back to
your point about feeling privileged and
i think sometimes it's important to
recognize when we are feeling privileged
and so something you know sometimes this
leads to an expectation that we deserve
more but I also feel and I'm biased that
that we are capable of doing great
things so I wonder from an executives
point of view how you look at young
talent that come into your company and
hunger for you know for the next step
that are two steps ahead of them and are
they ready for that I watch very closely
one thing I watch very closely in terms
of what how people are performing in
their current jobs and my alarm bells
are going on if people continuously talk
about the next step in some instances
it's probably very right and then the
question is is a person in a job who is
too small for him or is he able to
actually stretch himself him or herself
at the higher level but it's very
dangerous if you try to do things where
you do things with the anticipation I
have a write of this and that and that
and and this is a very very valuable
question what you are asked a very
important one and to find the right
balance can only be given at an
individual basis but never look out
doing things in a certain way today
because I expect something from the
organization tomorrow I think this can
never work and will never work rather
try to look in to find an environment
where you have a mentorship and
leadership environment where you can
engage yourself and leverage yourself
early on as part of the great performing
team because early on in life the
biggest lever what you have is the high
performance team aspect which was asked
early here
it's not individual it's actually the
team environment
and then you will drive on it it's the
question can only be asked individually
but it's a very very important question
with your vos we have time for one more
question
No
anyways I think it was this Stuxnet
computer or this tax net the Stuxnet is
a great business opportunity because now
many industrial companies have realized
the danger of being actually part of a
of a portable computer or of a computer
environment and we produce in our
automation control division actually
proprietary solutions and since stack
sneak has hit the drive to the little
bit more expensive proprietary solution
from Siemens the amount is going out but
it's a serious danger I mean you have
not asked about the danger absolutely
this is a venture there is no question
and we have now more and more customers
who are looking into their in the
industrial control environments to
really make sure we are weak points so
we're doing a lot of so-called health
checks for many of our customers at this
moment in time because this has
obviously created a much heightened
awareness compared to before solution
I'd like to say thank you very much for
attending the GSB today we really
appreciate